did you have the crazy like standards
like the 300 k 200k engagement ring
like no
i didn't have those crazy standards
um i was more of like the men hating
type of girl so so i
i fluctuated around the system or around
the feminism i call it like
there's different phases of feminism
there's like the pretty feminists that
kind of get away with saying like i need
a 200 000 ring right or um i'm gonna
sell myself on only fans like that type
of feminist and then you have the other
feminists that are like blue haired
feminists
and i was i kind of was in between both
because i did shave my head and dyed my
hair blue but i
also was that type of person who was
like i'm pretty enough to wear
like i can get i can get by so
do you find that as feminists like get
older like they can get away with less
stuff is that like a thing do you think
yeah i think you know as the red pillars
like to say
once you hit that wall or once you
approach the wall it's really hard to
it's really it's very unforgiving right
so like
you know in your 20s you probably get
away with more you probably get away
with more like craziness you get away
with more like in relationships and in
dating and then once you hit
especially like your later 20s to your
early 30s i would say some women like to
push that to like
late 30s
um
you kind of start realizing or hopefully
coming to terms with the fact that
life's not how you were playing it for a
while so really so you actually do think
that like the biological imperative like
sort of molded you to kind of go away
from that a little bit
yeah i mean i grew up in a very
traditional household my mom
took care of the household and my dad
went out and worked full-time like he
brought in income
so i grew up very very traditional
minded so
when i decided to go down the feminist
route and i didn't even know that that's
what i was doing and i think that that's
the biggest trap or the the biggest
thing that women don't understand is
that
it's not like you choose to be a
feminist like
i think the media and social media and
you know tv all of that stuff plays a
huge impact on us as women like growing
up
and yeah i just you know i don't think
that women necessarily walk into and be
like yeah i'm gonna be like i'm gonna
hate men it's just like what the
narrative is and it's like i want to be
as cool as the narrative like i want to
i want to be like these other women who
are saying the same thing so it's more
of like
women trying to fit in if that makes
sense and not necessarily
well and it started for you because you
worked on a boat or i can't i can't
remember the exact job but you're an
engineer like in an all-male dominated
field you said that was where it started
or did i forget a phase no so it kind of
so it kind of started in high school
so i
i don't
my mom i actually was talking to my mom
about it today so
as i mentioned in previous videos and
stuff on my channel there had there was
infidelity in my house and so when i
started noticing that at a very young
age i was like i need to take care of
myself i can't rely on a man and that
was my conclusion based off of the
experiences that i had
then
i got propelled into or i propelled
myself into male dominated industries i
am an engineer i'm a mechanical engineer
like studied robotics and then
i went to go work for an oil company
where i was on an offshore rig
in the middle of nowhere for like a
month at a time or like i just i was
around men all the time so
when i started working with men it was
more of that like
i was doing it to myself i went into a
male dominated industry thinking that
i'm gonna be this
like
i don't know that i'm gonna like
experience a different type of world
like no they treated me like one of the
brothers like they treated me as one of
the guys
they didn't say like oh here's a dainty
little girl like you wanted to play with
the boys play with the boys like
that's what it was and so
i myself had a lot of
anger towards them but they treated me
like
one of them and i earned respect with
them because
i you know
i
would shoot the [ __ ] with them i would
say like i would i would banter with
them right but then that also affected
my dating life where i was like
okay well i have this
i wouldn't call it like a luxe job but i
make
six figures at the age of like 20
something right
so then i was like this is translating
into my dating life because now i'm like
i can't date a guy that makes less than
what i do
or he's trash like that was my mindset
it wasn't
it wasn't that i was like
it i don't know it wasn't so that it was
so blatant in my face but that's just
what i came up with i was like well if i
make six figures he has to make six
figures too that only makes sense yeah
you know so
that's kind of how i saw it
and then over time that slowly went away
yeah you get humbled by life
you get humbled so many times it was it
was funny because the thing that humbled
me the thing that humbled me was i left
that six figure job um and then i
started my own company and i struggled
for a long time people don't understand
that like entrepreneurs
struggle and they don't necessarily make
money right away
so i was
like i was like working at a restaurant
job i was doing all this other stuff to
like try to make money while running my
business and then i finally sold that
business and started i started another
one but like you go through these
failures and through these ups and downs
and you realize wow like
it's not all about money
and that's not and that's not how you
should be defined and i think as a
society we've put a lot of emphasis on
money as like
as an indicator for success and
happiness and i think that's a crock of
crap
well and life is so long too you have no
idea where they're going to be in 20
years 30 years like my dad said a lot of
people that seem like early winners like
aren't actually the winners like in the
long run because you know
success that comes like that can go like
that
yeah absolutely
garyvee says something similar too you
know he says like a lot of these
entrepreneur entrepreneurs say the same
thing it's a marathon not a sprint if
it's a sprint for you it's going to
end very quickly and you have to
understand that it's like a long slog
and
you know once you get humbled by that
for sure because like working a
corporate job you get the cush
like paycheck and you have to do like
minimal work and when you work for
yourself you're literally like i have to
put food on my own table and if i don't
get it together
soon if i don't make something happen
soon i'm out of luck like i have to go
do something else so that was like a
that was a big hit too but then that was
like a whole new level of feminism
because
um when i moved to new york
when i started my companies my first
companies
this like
i i don't want to say it's all new new
york women are all new york like
entrepreneurs and stuff like that but
there's like a level of
of uh entitlement that comes with with
being a female entrepreneur and being a
minority entrepreneur
and
i fit those categories i'm a brazilian
woman i'm first generation american and
i'm
you know so all of those things were at
play so then everyone would tell me oh
you deserve this type of funding or you
need to do this because you deserve that
and i'm like for what for showing up
for being born a woman like a latina
woman like
but then at that point i was like okay i
drank the kool-aid so hard that i was
like yes i'm entitled to all this stuff
so it created a whole new level of
entitlement not so much like the hating
men part but the more
of the
i deserve this even though i didn't work
for it type of entitlement if that makes
sense no it totally does even on like
the live that i sent you the other day
of mine when i was like when it was it
wasn't like oh that would be super nice
if he bought me that ring it was like
buy me this i deserve your money and i
was
like i'm like baby girl listen i'm so
sorry to break it to you but you most
likely won't get a 200 000 ring
most likely
well and i asked like i asked my dad the
other day um i was just curious i was
like dad what's the most expensive gift
you bought mom
this is after 30 years of marriage
it was a hundred thousand dollar break
so half of that i'm like yeah hello guys
even guys that make money like they
don't want a girl that's like demanding
these crazy expensive gifts there's
these crazy standards they'll give it to
you out of like being nice sometimes but
it's like i think the entitlement where
a lot of girls go wrong
yeah and i think that
it's funny because like actually rich
people are very frugal
they don't spend money
just to spend money it's that like new
money
like that gatsby new money type of stuff
that they want to flash all of these
things so these guys that are paying
a crap ton of money to spoil their women
or take vacations
that just like we said
fast money leaves real quick like fast
money ends real fast so yeah if you want
to keep up with that lifestyle you have
to make more money and you have to give
up more like i'm so sorry to break it to
you but that's just how life works
well
well i think there's can you hear that
or no
i don't know what that was without it
it's my brother yelling next door
adam be quiet
i'm on an interview oh god
oh well hello
don't stop
kind of move out soon
no um well that's there's a difference
between like money and like wealth like
you could have money and not be wealthy
but damn generational wealth like
i think you kind of have to look at it
as like morally wrong to like spend on
like things that don't have an roi
consistently like here and there that's
fine but like
like look at what's his name the
facebook guy
mark zuckerberg same t-shirt every day
yeah he wears this and that's what uh
was steve jobs wore the same outfit
every single day like
like mark zuckerberg doesn't care about
like gucci loafers he doesn't drive the
nicest car
he drives like a regular car and
wears regular clothes
yeah and he's filthy rich so
wait um so you said something earlier
that i had a question on you said you
your dad was unfaithful how
like and you knew like how did you know
as a kid
um the men are really
men are not that great at lying
[Laughter]
um no it's just like there was like a
lot of things that there were a lot of
signs and obviously my mom knew
and i could
you know i could pick things up along
the way
um i could tell who they were and this
was not just on one occasion this was on
multiple occasions
um and yeah it was just it was
devastating for my family it was
devastating for my
mom
but the thing is is like over time when
i grew up um
and got to talk to my dad i realized
it's two sides it's not just one-sided
it wasn't just
he cheated and that was the end of that
it was
there were reasons why he cheated and
there was reasons why there was
infidelity and
lack of trust in the relationship and i
had to learn that from observing and
listening to both sides of the story if
i had just took taken my mom's side the
entire time i wouldn't have known the
full story and if i would have taken my
dad's side i would have known the full
story and so
it wasn't until like later on in life
like right before i got married where my
dad actually like sat me down and like
talked about this with me and um
unfortunately my dad passed away this
year so
so it was really it was good for me and
like and for my family as like closure
to understand
why things happened the way that they
happened um
but you know like
we're we're humans we people make
mistakes people especially who've been
married for a long time i'm actually
making a full-blown video about this
tomorrow i'm launching it tomorrow about
cheating um
in marriage and
in regular like dating relationships so
i'll go into that a little further
but but men and women cheat for very
different reasons so
so i'm
so and
if you don't want to like talk about any
of this on the air like feel free to
skip over it um
what did he say because i'm so curious
as to what like everyone always wants to
know like what goes on in the mind of a
cheater you know yeah
um i mean that's a very private thing
but but i will say like broadly
um if you
starve
if if you're a wife and you starve a man
of
physical touch
then um and like sex
then most likely they'll seek
sex in other places and vice versa if a
man is neglecting
his woman if she's not feeling
appreciated or heard or seen in the
relationship she will seek an emotional
she will seek emotional relationships
and emotional intimacy with someone else
and that's why men and women cheat
differently because men cheat for
gen this is generally speaking men cheat
for
sex because men need sex or men need
physical touch and relationships and
specifically in marriage and women on
the other hand crave emotional intimacy
and so
if you don't
meet that person's needs that person is
going to find it elsewhere so
well
no it's it's interesting you say that
because you know i always say like my
dad's like one of the
only like high value met or whatever
people don't think he like he exists and
people always think i'm lying but like
my dad's never cheated on my mom like
she's amazing doesn't drink doesn't do
that but one of the things my mom told
me
when i asked her what the um secret was
to a healthy marriage was to always just
say yes
that's what my mom that's what my mom
said on my like right before i got
married she's like when your husband
needs sex you give him sex
i was like okay
fair enough
[Music]
men are like and i'm sure a lot of guys
also agree men are very simple it's us
as women who are the most complicated
beings we you know men know how to
compartmentalize things they
compartmentalize sex they can
compartmentalize relationships work all
these other things as women everything
is like
intertwined mingled together
mashed and so
it becomes hard to
like
deserve compartmentalize that as a woman
if that makes sense yeah
you know what's one thing that i
realized um
but not not until i was like a couple
years ago
men tell you exactly what they want we
just don't listen
are you kidding me like half of the cop
if women just read my comment section if
women just read
your comment section or anyone else in
the manosphere they would know exactly
what men want like it's really not a
riddle it's not like
a physics problem
it's not rocket science men need
a few things and if women started like
listening to that they might
be successful in relationships
shocking
well you have all these like female
mostly some male dating coaches telling
like women to play these games and i
think it's sometimes because like to be
honest like games work on women not not
all the time but a lot of women like the
games work on but like men are built
like us like you know what i mean like
they just they just look at like the
games and like
playing hard to get all that stuff is
just like tiring
yeah i don't i don't really like games i
don't believe in games whatsoever i
think the best thing that the the reason
why
like first of all i was attracted to my
husband but the reason why i stayed with
my husband is because
we could both be transparent and not
play games and i felt comfortable with
him not playing games i was like this
man has integrity he has like morals and
values and he stands on those things but
these games is the games are what like
are is the issue i believe because
you know women are being told to have
game and play these games and men are
being told to play these games like you
go on tick-tock and it's all bad advice
it's all like toxic tick-tock advice i'm
like
why are
young people listening to this garbage
you know
and
and honestly like it's because people
crave this like toxic
these toxic relationships because that's
all they know that's all they've seen
that's all they've interacted with and
it's sad it's really sad to me and
that's why i
speak facts or truth and all this other
stuff and hopefully like more women are
coming to my channel but
it's really hard like women
don't like to hear the truth